We on.
Alright,
good evening.
Good evening. Welcome. How are you guys? Good to see you.
Unbelievable. Okay. It's what I like to hear. Great.
Come on in. Uh, I don't believe you. No.
Glad you guys are here. If you're new. Thanks for coming.
If you're second time around, thanks for coming back.
So anyway, uh, if you haven't signed in already, David,
do you want to explain that or did you already No.
This letter. Check by your name.
If you're on the roster, if you're not, just sign it.
We got lines over there,
but you don't have to sign if you're brand new.
We've got an outline, a syllabus, uh, that just kind of
as a guide to the class with a calendar on it.
Um, we've got a theme verse, memory verse that, uh,
I'm passing out a verse that's relevant to the whole class
for each of our sessions.
And, uh, and then there's also class notes avail available.
If you need a pen, uh, flag David down. Let him know.
Also, uh, if you would like to follow along as part of this
class, or if this is your first and only class
and you just wanna read the book we're talking about either
way, uh, we've got a couple more copies.
The book is Bible Doctrine by Wayne Gruden.
If you're familiar with this book, Wayne Gruden
actually has one that's twice this size.
And, uh, if you're really gung-ho, I'd recommend you buy
that one and kind of read the whole thing.
But, uh, this one's a shorter version.
There's actually one that is half as long as this one.
And so it's an either even more accessible version
that if you'd like to check that out, you can do it as well.
But the class textbook is this book
right here, Bible doctrine.
So, um, we got I think two of those.
They're going for $22 each. We don't make money off that.
They actually lose a few pennies if we do it that way.
But anyway, um, that was the cheapest I could find it.
So let's see.
Alright, let me pray for us and we'll get started.
Almighty God, we thank you for this opportunity
to come together as your people in this place.
God, we thank you for the light of your word,
that your word says that it is your word.
That it is a light to our feet. It is a lamp to our path.
And I pray that you would give us eyes to see and pray.
In fact, with the psalmist, we would pray, Lord,
open our eyes that we would behold
wonderful things in your word.
And I pray you'd speak to us now, I pray.
Speak to us as we gather, Lord.
Uh, we want to not just learn more about you,
but we also want to get to know you better personally.
And we want to be changed
By the knowledge of who you are.
We want to reflect you rightly in the world.
And so God, we pray that you come have your way in our lives
through Jesus name.
Amen. Alright, uh, all rice is presenting leading us today.
So if you want come on up, we will dive in.
Please sign the roll
stand or do you wanna hold it?
I'll hold it, sir.
So, uh, I'm the son of a cowboy.
And so, uh, I feel that
whenever I'm around really smart people,
I don't understand things very well.
But, uh, so in this room there are a lot of smart people.
You know, we've got Aaron, we've got Dan, we've got pr,
Steve, a bunch of got Mark.
So they may be able to help us a little bit.
But I thought I would, uh, one thing
that I can do is start with an analogy.
'cause sometimes I don't understand something,
but an analogy helps me.
So I want you to imagine this is a little brighter.
I was gonna bring the bright one,
but I thought it would knock out your redness.
So that's, you know, we don't want that.
So I want you to imagine that the Bible is the sun.
Okay? Now, the sun's got a lot
of good things going for it, right?
What are some things that the sun is good for?
Like light, right? So enlightenment, what else?
Life, heat, life. What else?
Navigation, gravitation, we revolve around it.
Uh, so basically the sun is pretty much the whole
show for our solar system.
Now, the bad news about that is
that if we look at the sun in the wrong way,
it can do us damage.
We have to look at the sun in the right way, right?
Um, and so that's my analogy in the upper left
for the Bible.
The word of God. So this week we're gonna be looking
at the sun, the Bible itself.
Next week we're gonna be thinking about
where we stand in relationship to the sun
and through what sort of goggles.
We look at the sun, that's called terminus, right?
We're gonna do that later this week.
We're just focusing on the notion
of the word of God.
Um, now the stuff that we're gonna talk about today,
often I'll start out with a question
because I think, you know, again,
there's people smarter than me in here.
And so we can get collective wisdom.
Then I may have something to say related
to the sheet of paper there.
But I want us to think about this in two ways.
I want us to think about the Bible
as it relates to ourselves.
What does it do for us?
So for example, encouragement,
enlightenment, right, guidance.
But a lot of this stuff we're gonna cover.
Y'all are dang smart that you may say, I know that.
But then I want you to think about how this can help others.
And this is called apologetics. Okay?
So apologetics is a weird word from the Greek,
and it sounds like we're supposed to be apologizing
for things, but really it just means
from the Greek, a defense.
So not only can we learn about the greatness
and the importance of the Bible for ourselves,
but along the way, I mean, how many times do we have people
that we know that say things about the Bible
that aren't true, and we can, uh, explain to them
or defend the validity and the power of the Bible?
Make sense? Mm-hmm. Okay.
So first question that I want to dive into today
is how do we as human beings
know anything about God?
I've been thinking about the notion of, uh, atheism.
Okay? And I used to be a professor guy
and think about other cultures,
and I was trying to think,
was there ever a civilization that was atheist?
And I can't think of it.
I mean, whenever civilization you study,
they believe in the divine.
They believe the divine is the cause of things.
Now, sometimes they believe in polytheism, usually the lots
of gods, but everyone seems
to have an innate concept of the divine,
and they believe certain things about the divine.
How do we know that? How do they know that?
How do, how do humans know about that? Sorry?
Creation. Creation.
So Romans one tells us, Romans chapter one says
that when we just look at the creation, also, lots
of the Psalms talk about this on 1 0 4.
Uh, that when we look at the creation,
we can deduce certain things about God.
So what are some things we can deduce about creation?
By the way, this is a fancy theological term called
general revelation.
Okay? So
what we know in general about God from stuff he's done.
So what are some things we can know about God
through what's called general revelation or creation?
Order? Order. Things are well ordered. Okay?
So sometimes I'll be debating with like,
really smart atheists,
and they say, well, what is some proof that God
has designed things with, with great precision?
And I said, okay, take a look at the moon.
Take a look at the sun.
They're exactly the same size from our perspective on earth.
The moon is a certain distance.
The sun is 400 times farther,
and it's exactly 400 times larger.
And they're a perfect alignment so
that the moon covers the sun.
So we can see a thing called the aurora of the sun.
What are the odds of that happening by chance?
You see what I'm saying? So there's order. Good. What else?
How else do we know about? What else can we know about God?
Beauty. Beauty?
Okay, we can go about, man, that's, that's pretty.
I remember one time David Barnes was telling me a story
about he was talking to a kid camp, pardon me, David,
if I'm treading on your stories.
He was talking to a kid at camp that he was witnessing to,
and the kid was like, yeah, I don't believe in God.
I don't believe any, any of that. And
they happened to be on a beach.
And David goes, look at this beach.
And the kid stared at for her,
he goes, okay, I believe in God.
Okay, so beauty, what else? Provision.
Provision. We got, we got stuff to eat.
You know, I mean, all creatures are in this kind of harmony
where they're all eating each other, eating plants.
And we got all this teaming life compared to, I don't know,
say the moon, which is, you know, isn't working out for it.
Um, what else? Power. Power.
Got a lot of power. Solar power, got wind, power, got water,
power, thunder, tornadoes.
You ever heard of those in Oklahoma? Uh, what else?
Creativity. Creativity.
Um, I read a, a poet who was a, also a theologian,
and she made this great statement.
She said, at the moment in Genesis,
when it says God made humans in God's image, right?
Right at the beginning she said, at that point,
what do we know about God?
He's the creation. So human beings themselves
innately have this creation, this power to create.
What else? Attention to detail. Attention to details.
Okay? Uh, you know, there's a great moment in the,
the movie, Rudy, anybody ever seen Rudy?
Yes. Where the priest looks at Rudy,
and this says, I know two things.
There is a God and I'm not him. Okay?
You look around and you go, Psalm, bigger
and smarter than me made this stuff right?
Okay? So we can know a lot about God
through what's called general revelation.
I keep just looking around at stuff,
but now we're talking about the Bible.
What might we know from the Bible about God?
That we wouldn't learn from creation?
By the way, uh, the,
the Bible when we're talking about it is called, uh,
special revelation, which is a fancy way
to send of the Bible, right?
So what do we know about God,
uh, from the Bible?
That, that we, you know, that's additional to
what we know from creation.
He loves people a lot, loves people enough to die, right?
Okay. That's,
that's not something you see when you look at
Jupiter, right?
Right. What else?
What other things? He has a grand, a grand story.
He has a grand story.
He is invested himself in human history.
And I made a little chart up here, and, uh, it's perfect
because, uh, university,
we don't have markers that work very well.
And so I pick ones that don't work very well, tr
of course came up and picked the perfect one.
But, uh, if we think about, uh, a,
a grand history here, the Old Testament was written
about a thousand year period,
and I'm just fudging some of these numbers.
Sometimes they're gonna be a century off.
Sometimes they're gonna be a decade or two off.
'cause scholars disagree. But about 1450 BC when Moses was
bopping around to about 450 BC is when the Old
Testament was written, okay?
Then from about four 50 BC
to about four BC is called the inter testim period.
So the Old Testament's already ended.
Stuff is happening,
but there's no more writing in the, in in the Bible,
the, in the camp, right?
Then we had the New Testament written over a period
of about 94 years
or so from four BC when Jesus, about the time Jesus was born
to about the time the Apostle John dies,
which is about 90 or to 180.
Then we have the early church.
And I designated that from about 90 ad
to 4 76 ad I picked 4 76.
'cause that's when the Roman Empire fell.
And then we have about a thousand years of
what I call middle ages.
And I'm gonna refer to those as the Catholic Middle Ages.
'cause it was really only one church
in Western Europe in the Middle Ages.
And it was the Catholic church.
And partly because they were awesome, but probably
'cause they wouldn't have it any other way.
If there were cults or sex, they, they eliminated. Right?
And then starting with the 1517, we have the beginning of
what are called the Protestants.
And, uh, what are the Protestants says,
as Mark said last week, they're protesting
what they consider the abuses
that the Catholic church had developed
over that thousand years.
And they want to go back to the Bible, okay?
And they want to their religion to reflect more like
what they see in the first century in the
Book of Acts and so on.
Okay? And our church is part of
that Protestant tradition.
But notice how God has interweaved
himself throughout human history.
I mean, from Adam to Abraham, to Moses.
He just will say, Moses, write this down here.
I'll write the first part of it. Okay?
It's called the Bible. Now I want you
to write the rest of it down.
Okay? And so he's interactive.
What else do we know about God from the Bible?
His essence, or who he is, is his essence, who he is.
So we've got a bunch of Latin theological terms like
omniscient, immortal, infinite, okay?
Omnipresent. And those words aren't in the Bible,
but the God of the Bible is those things.
And so he's, he really is bigger than us. Okay?
And so those are the two kinds of revelation.
General, special.
Now, the next question is, if the Bible
a special revelation, I'm gonna call it the word of God.
Some reason why I say the word of God, I wanna go
to Sean Cony, right?
The water of God, right?
Uh, why I'm gonna do everything of Sean.
Um, so I thought David Barbon
was gonna come up and take the mic.
So when we're thinking about the word of God, uh,
the question is who interprets it?
So for the Catholic Middle Ages for a thousand years,
they came to the conclusion that the only group
that can properly interpret the Bible
is the Catholic church.
Okay? And they can interpret the Bible, uh, by the way,
for them, for Catholic, and I, I love Catholics
and my, my daughter and son-in-law are about
Catholics and my grandson.
But we're different, right?
And we gotta know what the differences are.
Uh, Catholics have
as their absolute central authority for their religion.
Not the Bible. Protestants, it's the Bible.
It's called sola scripture. Another fancy Latin term, right?
Sola scripture. But the Catholics hold that the authority
for the, for their religion is the church.
And that includes things like pub pronouncements of pubs,
but mainly church councils and so on, right?
And so when there's a Bible passage, the
Catholics will interpret that
and say, this is what it means.
And the Catholics are supposed to believe it that way.
Does that make sense? Now, in 1517,
we began, uh,
a guy named Martin Luther began what's called the
Protestant Reformation.
And they came up with some concepts, which
basically leaves it up to the individual Christian
to interpret scripture.
Um, and one, as I said, so scripture,
which means the Bible is the supreme authority in all
matters of doctrine and practice.
And the other is the priesthood of the believer.
So, uh, I'm a Catholic, I might say,
I don't understand this scripture passage.
And the priest may say it means this
because that's the tradition handed down.
What we're on our own is Protestants except
for the Holy Spirit, which is really helpful.
Okay? So it is our job.
There's no one between us and God Almighty,
but the Holy Spirit.
And that is enough 'cause for Christians,
the Holy Spirit's living inside us.
And it is the Holy Spirit who helps us
interpret the scripture, which the Holy Spirit
helped people write.
So that's a pretty good means to understand the book,
that the Holy Spirit inspired people.
Um, so the next question is
how do we interpret the scripture?
Well, we're gonna be talking about that next week.
That's got to do with goggles looking at the sun, okay?
Uh, and that's called hermeneutics.
Not to be confused with Herman Munster
at a certain age, okay?
Uh, no one's my age.
So at the bottom it says, within the reformation
and within theological planners, prior to it,
a movement called reform theology,
sometimes covenant theology.
This is the bottom of paper.
One that we have in there, emphasizes the authority
of scripture, the sovereignty of God, salvation by grace
through Christ, the necessity of evangelism.
And we at Henderson Hills are a part of
that reform theology tradition.
And so the systematic theology course will view the Bible
from that theological perspective.
Our assumptions, number one, the Bible is true,
and our is our only absolute standard of truth.
Sola scripture, uh, the God of the Bible exists
and is who the Bible says he is.
And we will teach from a reform theological perspective.
We're gonna kick around the idea later.
A thing called narcy.
I'm not sure when will do that, maybe today.
Um, but let's go back to
the question of the Bible.
So what is the Bible?
If I brought in a copy of the new of pardon
of the Living Bible, which was the kind
of hippie hipster bible right from the sixties.
Okay? You know, I've read part of that.
Uh, this is a quote from Ecclesiastes nine eight,
from the Living Bible, wear fine clothes
with a dash, a colo.
Now in the King James, it says, anoint your head with oil.
Okay? But the living
or the dash, I probably could use a little poem.
My life. Um, so is the Living Bible.
The Bible is is ESB, the Bible.
The King James. King James. King James. Yeah.
When I was a kid, I heard, by the way, when I was a kid,
I was given a King James Bible by the,
the Baptist church that I was going to.
And uh, I said, oh, is this the Bible?
And someone out wrote, there were joking.
They said, if it's good enough
for Jesus, it's good enough for us.
The okay. Uh, so what is the Bible?
Is it, is it new standard update? I like that one.
I like the new living. Um,
I like the English version
with all the notes in the E You know that with the EE
What about the Swahili version?
Yeah. What about the Swahili version?
You know, I do mission work in Wales
and they have a Welsh Bible, and sometimes I open it up
and I'm as confused as I amm
because still trying to learn Welsh,
after, you know, 15 years, we even seriously,
like the Ethiopian Bible,
it has a million other books in it.
Okay, we'll talk about that.
Yeah, we're gonna talk about that later.
So what is the Bible?
Well, John one isn't
the word, okay?
So at one level the word is Jesus Christ
himself, right?
Because John is using a euphemism
for Jesus Christs, okay?
And so we have to believe that the word
that is the second person of the Trinity is absolutely
manifested in, uh, a book that we might hold.
So I'll pull out the one that I tend to bring to church.
This is the ESP.
We have to believe that, uh, Jesus is in this,
in his essence, by the Holy Spirit,
but also the Father, right?
But when I talk about the word, let's talk about a term
called the cannon.
And I don't mean yare parent, that's take the kind
s**t that SME in.
I'm talking about C-A-N-O-N.
And uh, basically it just means
the books in this thing uphold divided into Old Testament
and New Testament, 66.
Um, so the canon, what
is the canon?
How do we know what the Bible is? What is it?
Anybody inspired Word of God?
Okay, inspired word of God, he said
as I almost slammed those by word of God.
Yeah, okay. That's the inspired word of God.
But how do we define it?
Because for example, as we're gonna see, uh,
do you know there are books that the Bible mentions
that we don't have anymore 17 of them.
Do you know the Catholics have a bunch more books
in the Bible than we do?
Do you know, there's hundreds of other scriptures out there
that don't make either of those cuts.
Okay? So how do we define the Bible?
How do we know where it comes from?
Let me, uh, make a suggestion for you.
This is just my take, okay?
I would argue that the original Hebrew arama
and Greek manuscripts, the autographs
of the original author, uh, is the Bible.
So when Paul dictated to whoever so glad,
and Savannah said, which St.
Paul, uh, when John wrote stuff down,
when Luke wrote stuff down, uh,
When God wrote stuff down and handed it to Moses,
and then he, God dictated to Moses that moment
was the Bible in three different languages.
In the Old Testament is Hebrew, their passages of Daniel
that are an Aramaic, I think,
and then also in the New Testament is Greek, okay?
So to me, those are capital B Bible.
But the good news is, is
that the translations we have in the Bible
are basically great for everyday use and,
and for spiritual enlightenment.
But it's awfully fun to look back at the Hebrew,
the Greek and the Aramaic.
I don't know Aramaic and I dunno,
Hebrew, but you see what I'm saying?
Mm-hmm. Is that, that's, that's
The, the idea.
But let's jump into some of these other scriptures.
And as I said, the Old Testament was written
from about 1450 to about four 50 ad okay?
Uh, I mean BC yes, but Jesus comes along about four bcs.
So what was the Old Testament for Jesus?
The answer is, it's exactly the same Old Testament we have
in our Protestant Bible.
It was sort of codified about 200 bc.
So almost 200 years
before Jesus, it was unofficially codified.
That's what we know, what Jesus read.
And then about 90 ad
after, you know, John, while John, uh, apostle John was,
was dying somewhere, probably, uh,
there was a synagogue called Jam
or Jamian, where the Jews officially said,
this is the Old Testament, but it's exactly what Jesus had.
So what about all the scriptures
that were written in this time that isn't in the canon?
And what about the scriptures in the intestinal period
that isn't in the canon?
How do we know they're not?
Well, that is called the Catholic Apal.
And I brought an old copy of one of my Bibles with Roy
and it, I'm gonna hand this around.
And where the bookmark is, that is
where the apocrypha starts.
It's not very far, okay?
But you can take a look at some of the scriptures in there.
There's the wisdom of solving, okay?
Uh, when I was in college, I was,
I was a Christian when I became 11,
but I got, you know, thinking about this stuff
and I decided to read every word of the Catholicism.
Uh, and then I started reading a bunch of the other stuff.
We'll talk about that in a minute.
So what about all the Catholic apoc?
But what happened was, it was a really smart early church
thinker, and, uh, he,
uh, sorry, I'm blanking out for a second.
So what he did was, uh, he decided
to translate the Bible into Latin.
His name was Jerome, okay?
And he translated the Bible into Latin,
and that was the big hit Bible for,
you know, a thousand years.
Okay? And what he did was, is he said, this is the Bible
exactly the same as the Protestant pan,
but in the back, he said, for additional reading, okay?
And he said, this isn't scripture, but it's in the back.
It's the apora for additional reading.
And it's good reading. I, I don't have a problem reading the
Apora, but what happened was Jerome said,
it's not scripture, but later on, the Catholic said, yeah,
it's so, in a way it's not so much
that Protestants took away scripture from the Bible, it's
that the Catholics added it.
Does that make sense? And
there's a lot of good stuff in there.
Wisdom of song. Now, two funny ones are,
they're further adventures of Daniel the prophet, okay?
And basically Daniel becomes Sherlock Holmes,
and he is solving these really cool mysteries,
and they're great to read.
Okay? I don't believe them, you know, but,
but they're, they're really awesome.
One involves a dragon, okay?
So, uh, and one kind of starts the concept
of cross-examination, but enough of that.
So I, I read 'em all if you want read the, uh,
Catholic apra fine.
It's, it's a lot of, it's, you know, pretty good reading.
Is it in there Scripture? No. How do we know?
Well, here's a, I'm gonna give you a lot
of clues later why it's not.
But here's a good clue.
It's good enough for Jesus, it's good enough for us.
None of the Catholic talk
was in the Old Testament that Jesus wrote.
Okay, here's another answer.
Jesus never refers to the Catholic apocrypha one time,
nor does any other writer of the New Testament.
Okay? So good for additional reading.
But again, if the, what we have here is good enough
for Jesus, the Old Testament, it's good enough for us.
And we got, I got more about that later. Okay?
What about the New Testament?
By the way, there's some really good stuff in the
Inner Testament stuff.
So have you ever heard, I love this name,
it's a Jewish name, but it sounds Scottish to me.
You ever heard of the Maccabees?
Our schools, they sound Scottish.
Uh, well, all about the Maccabees are there and I've read it
and it's good swashbuckling stuff,
and it's where we get Hanukkah okay,
that, that comes in that.
I hope I didn't mispronounce that. Okay.
Um, is this all boring stuff of this stuff? You guys know?
Okay, the board, the elders are board, okay, I got question.
Sorry. That's the one to, is that the first five? Yes.
Tora is the, uh, sort of Old Testament, a Jewish notion
of just the first five books in the Bible.
The, uh, when the Jews are,
or Jesus, when he fought about the Old Testament,
he broke it up into three parts.
It was the law, which is the Torah, the five books,
the prophets, which is the prophets.
And then for some reason, the other bit is the writings,
which is, you know, Proverbs and,
and all, all that sort of stuff.
Okay? Um, that's how, that's how they, they broke it up,
the Jews and Jesus Does that, did that answer your question?
Okay. Okay. Uh, any other questions?
I guess I don't know how much time, just real quick. Yeah.
You mentioned that Jesus, um, never,
Like you said, it is that Jesus
of course never mentions the apocryphal,
but do we have evidence that Jesus
referenced every other aspect of real testament?
Yes. He mentioned every book of the Bible
except four of them.
And Esther, now that doesn't mean anything against him
because he was just talking about stuff, so he didn't have
to be categorical and mention all of them,
but he's mentioned all of them,
but four of them, I have them somewhere in my notes here.
Um, but all the other Old Testament, he,
he directly mentions
and the other apostles mentioned a along those two
From the Lord to May, it says Jesus
through the scripture Psalm yes, prophet
That again, On the road to May,
which is in the last chapter of Luke, uh, Jesus,
it says he start, he went into the scripture beginning
with Moses, the Psalms, and the prophets,
and talking about all things concerning himself.
You had mentioned in specific He had, he went
through an open scriptures,
By the way, Jesus himself,
and it's somewhere in here, uh,
says basically the Old Testament spots was Zach
arrived in the four fields.
So he himself indirectly is saying,
I don't count the intestinal stuff. Does that make sense
Now? Yeah.
Um, you're,
the note you're looking for is on page five.
Oh, read it. Um, it's talking about not Jesus.
T it says, the New Testament refers
to virtually every Old Testament book except to Ezra,
Nehemiah, Esther, Ecclesiastes, and Psalm saw.
Okay.
Um, okay, so
that is the Catholic apocryphal.
Now the next question is, uh,
the Bible itself mentions are quote 17 books,
which we no longer have.
And the fancy scholarly work for that is called a stand,
means we don't have it around the anymore.
Uh, and, uh, there are 17 books that the Bible mentions.
And so one, if you were a, an atheist
or something, you'd say, well,
we don't even have all the Bible.
The Bible itself tells us we don't have all the Bible.
Is that true? Well, here's answer, I don't know.
Uh, we have everything that we need in the Bible
that we have now,
but it's likely that the Bible was referring to these books
for more references.
So for example, uh, it'll say,
and if you want to hear more about that battle,
why don't you read about it more in the
Battle of the Wars Bull.
So, uh, we know that Paul, for example, uh,
in the New Testament, referred to
non-Christian Greek philosophers sometimes to say,
as they would say,
but that doesn't make them the Bible, right?